Fantastic work.
You've now created a master
resume spreadsheet.
Selected keywords and
phrases for a target job.
And tailored your career
experience to fit on one page.
You have also organized your resume
sections in a logical order.
Your final step is to perfect
the visual style of your resume.
Though this stage may seem tedious,
it helps communicate your attention to
detail and can be an opportunity
to show your personality.
To begin, be sure your name is
the largest text on the page.
Make titles, sub-categories, dates and
locations distinct from one another.
To do so we recommend using
text formatting like bold,
italics, spacing and size.
Though some may choose to use color
to make text visually distinct,
keep it minimal and subtle.
We found that color works best,
if it all, when used after you've
explored the limits of text formatting.
If you aren't graphically gifted
simplicity might be your best bet.
Keep text aligned to the left side and
use the entirety of the page.
If you're short on space,
widen your margins.
Use single spacing and font that are
easy to read and not overly stylized.
Review the checklist on the instructor
notes to see if your resume
is up to par.